I am Meghan Hall.
I am going to be speaking today
on the experience of being
the only R user in my workplace.
I'm so excited to
give this talk.
I'm sorry I am not there
in person as planned,
but I do have to
give a special thanks
to the conference organizer
who definitely handled my
very last minute switch
to presenting virtually instead.
The team I suppose
formerly known
as the RStudio, created these
great talk graphics for us.
But there is not quite
enough self promotion for my taste,
so feel free to
follow me on Twitter.
But really, just
want to thank you
all so much for
watching my talk and I
want to give kind
of a special shout
out welcome to anyone who
might be watching virtually.
Maybe watching
this recording
when it's posted later.
Maybe someone who's even
a little earlier in there
R journey.
And because this
talk is also for you.
There should be time at the
end of talk for questions,
if any come up
while I'm speaking.
You can put them at
Slido with the hashtag,
or I'll also be around the
Discord server this afternoon
if there's any topic that you
want to chat further about.
So this is my laptop.
It looks like a lot of
your laptops out there.
But to me, this is the
most special laptop
of all, because
this laptop is why
I learned are to set
the stage a little bit.
I've been working
as a data professional
for over seven years in
higher ed administration.
I currently work at Brown
University as a data manager
and in that role
I am really kind
of the data person in a
functional business office.
I don't work in
I.T., I don't work
on a data team, a lot of other
data fluent people around me.
And as you can imagine,
my [inaudible] is Excel mostly.
And so kind of at the
beginning of my career
I was also using Excel
for my data analysis
because again, that was the
atmosphere that I was in.
And then a few years later I
started getting into hockey
and because I am a
numbers person, whatever
other euphemism you
prefer to use for nerd,
I pretty quickly
started gravitating
to the analytics
side of the game,
started kind of getting involved
in the public sports analytics
community.
And as I started embarking
on my own analysis,
I started using
Excel because that
is what I was most
recently familiar with.
So what I used to work for a
lot of the data analysis work
that I. But let me tell
you, this lovely laptop
that you see here that I
still have and still this 2015
MacBook Air could not
handle Excel files that
had over a million
just didn't work.
Crash I couldn't even filter
couldn't even do basic stuff.
So out of technical
necessity, I started learning.
R. I had been somewhat [iaudible] in R
and SAS and Stata from grad school
but decided to pursue
learning because truly it
seemed like it had the
most welcoming and kind
of inclusive community and
it seemed like something that
was really learnable to me.
And so an experience that many of
you are probably familiar with.
I became much happier when
I was doing my data analysis
with as is much more suited to
that type of data analysis work
than Excel is.
But again, even though
I was very happy
using R for the sports
analytics work
that I was doing on the side,
it took me a little while
to incorporate all of that R
knowledge into my work,
and the work I was doing for
money because again, as I said,
no one around me was using R.
So it didn't seem a very
welcoming environment
to start using it.
So I realized I don't need to
spend a lot of time preaching
to this crowd.
That R is great
because we all know
that R is a really
ideal tool for dealing
with reproducible data analysis.
Right and one of the things that
is kind of magical and amazing
about R is that you can use R
for your entire data analysis
workflow.
But I would argue that
kind of equally amazing
is you don't have to use R
for your entire data analysis
workflow.
That might work for
a lot of people,
but it might not
work for everyone.
Might not work for
you if it doesn't
fit within the constraints you
might have upon you at work.
And again, I think
it's I would argue
that it's like equally great
kind of an equal strength of R
that even if you just kind
of use bits and pieces of R,
incorporate them into your
work, that really helps
solve your specific problems.
You don't need to use the entire
again, A to Z workflow of R
in order to get
those benefits of R.
And so you can really just focus
on what is possible for you
and what helps you
because it's for sure true
that there are struggles
to incorporating R
into a workflow that might not
feel very welcoming toward it.
But I'm going to today I'm
going to talk about some
of the struggles
that I have faced
going through that process, how
I've handled those struggles,
and how I still think they
are greatly outweighed
by the benefits you get of using
R again, even if you can only
use bits and pieces of
the entire R ecosystem.
So I hope that this talk will
be helpful and inspiring to you.
Whether you are you
yourself are starting
to think about using
at work, whether you're
like me and a lone
wolf, using artwork
in trying to kind of
spread the gospel,
I'm looking for some tips about
how to make that job easier.
Or maybe even you're involved
in helping usher other people
along similar journeys along
how to, how to incorporate R
into their workflow.
So hopefully this will
give you some tips on that.
So in addition to my
work in higher ed,
I also spent some time at
Zelus Analytics, which
is a sports analytics company.
And there I worked
as a data scientist
among a team of
other data scientists
in kind of a software
development team.
And there, my entire workflow
that I worked in was in R.
I was able to, within R,
write MySQL code directly
connect to the databases
to pull the data that I needed.
The products I created were in
R Markdown, all my analysis,
my visualizations, et cetera
and of course, everything
was controlled through
Git and version control.
And if you work in kind of a
traditional data role in a data
team that does not sound foreign
or special to you at all.
But I can tell you that
not all of us are so lucky.
It is true that not everyone
gets the luxury of choosing
their entire tech stack.
But again, if you work in
a role maybe slightly less
traditionally a data role,
or a data role that's
kind of embedded in a
lot of non data people,
if you work kind of far from
other tech friendly folks,
your options might be -- your tech
stack options might be limited
and not ideal,
which was certainly
my professional case.
So while going through
a couple of examples,
I'm going to focus
on my two best
tips for dealing with
that problem, which
is firstly to always try,
be creative, do as much in R
as possible, as
less as possible
in other tools.
And focus on what
is really realistic
for your situation,
not what's maybe ideal for
the general population,
someone in a more traditional
data science role.
So perhaps you can
access data through R.
I am very familiar
with this problem.
I cannot access my data through R
or I cannot connect directly
to the databases that
hold the data that I need.
I have to use another external
"Oracle-like report studio
software" in order
to access this data.
And so here's how I have finally
decided how I can develop
a program to help handle that.
So this is not a unique idea.
But any time I open a
new RStudio project,
I automatically set up some
files that I always use.
And my setup file is
really devoted specifically
to all of my
report decisions.
So again, the report,
the reporting software
through Oracle that I have
to use is pretty powerful.
It allows you to
make calculations,
create new fields.
You can write SQL, do some
pretty complicated filtering.
But I again prefer to keep
all of that stuff in Ar
as much as possible so I can
control change more easily,
reproduce the code
that I want, and write
that code in the language
that I want to write it.
So within my setup files, I
document all report decisions
like the name of the report
where the report was located,
any dates, filters,
et cetera and I also
make sure that those reports
themselves are pretty
broad population parameterize.
I'm mostly dealing
with people data
and I know that when I
want to go to my next steps
and analyze the data, I need to
create new fields and filter,
et cetera but I try to get the
biggest possible population,
the simplest version
of the report
that I can run in
this external software
so I can do again all of
the data manipulation work
in R -- again where
R is successful.
And this is just a
very simple example
of what one of my setup
files might look like.
They always start
with lots of comments.
Again, the when, where,
why, how of the report
and it's all just
convenient place
to again read in all of my data.
You also might need to
Dashboard elsewhere.
If it were up to me, all of
the end products of my work
would either be in R Markdown
or quarto or Shiny or something
like that.
But I work at a
Tableau organization.
I have to use Tableau and
it can be a little dicey
mentioning Tableau at an R
focus conference, especially
when I know there's a Shiny
talk going on at the same time
right now.
But it is a necessary tool
that some of us need to use.
And any time I
have a project that
involves any kind of
dashboard component,
I automatically create
a dashboard file.
And if you're not familiar with
tableau, Tableau actually is.
Have some pretty
advanced capabilities
when it comes to
dealing with data.
You can handle
relational data, you
can look at data at different
levels of detail, aggregations,
calculations, et cetera
that's all fine and good.
But again, I would
really prefer to do
all of that data
prep work in out
where I prefer the language.
I have all the I have
all the code in one code
file that I can much
more easily change,
track, reproduce
rather than having
them scattered all about the
Tableau software as it is.
So again, within
this dashboard file
that I create, if I
know I have a Tableau
component to my
analysis project,
I make sure I have all the code.
I create kind of
extra data files
at different levels
of aggregation
that I know I might need for
Tableau in any calculations
that I know that I'll need
to incorporate in my Tableau
dashboard.
And I also make sure I
save all of those data
files in a specific folder.
Again, this is a very
barebones example
of what that data of what
that dashboard file are file
might look like for my project.
But again, any code to create
anything specific for Tableau
goes there, and all
the various files
that I create automatically get
written into a special Tableau
special folder
usually just called
for Tableau that lives in that
project's working directory.
So that means that
when I actually
need to open Tableau again,
I just import all of the data
files in that one
specific folder,
and then I can use Tableau
for what Tableau is really
good at, admittedly,
which is efficiently,
making really beautiful and
interactive data visualizations
that fit with the
IT infrastructure
at my organization while
leaving, all of the things I
prefer to do in R any
kind of data prep work,
working, joining,
data, et cetera,
leaving that in are where
I can more easily track it.
And lastly, this might
be shocking to some
of you depending
on the type of role
that you are in, but not
all of us have access to get
or some kind of version control.
I don't, unfortunately.
And so within my data
prep, data analysis files,
any files where I'm kind of
writing code, making decisions
about data, I have a lot of
comments and more comments
than a lot of people.
But if I don't have access
to the collaboration
and communication benefits
of version control,
I need to do that collaboration
and communication somewhere.
And for me, it's just
easiest within my workflow
to use data comments
in my data files.
So I comment any type of
major decisions that get made.
And you can also really
just in the Comments
link to any kind of
supporting documentation.
Again, whether that's
an internal or even as
something as simple as
referencing like a March
25th email chain
you had with Ames,
where you decided to change
the definition of some metric.
Now, I know there is a
theory out there to you,
to some of you, this
might seem like,
whoa, that's a lot of comments
I won't show you in a while,
just not to scare you, because I
know there's a theory out there
that if your code has common and
your code isn't clear enough,
that code is only
clear enough when
it doesn't need any comments
to explain what's going on.
And that might be a perfectly
valid philosophy working theory
to have at some
organization in some setups.
But if you don't
have version control
and I certainly don't want
multiple versions of my data
prep files floating
around, I need
to use comments in order to
communicate and collaborate
with myself or with
someone else or more likely
myself in six months.
And so to that, I
would really again
focus on what's
kind of underlined
on the bottom of
the screen is focus
on what's realistic
for your situation,
even if it might not be.
I guess commonly
supported practice.
What people think is ideal
for the general population,
it's ideal for everyone.
Does not mean that it for you.
So given that their
struggles, they've
just demonstrated just
a handful of the ones
that I personally have had
to come up with techniques
in order to face.
They're definitely.
Challenges but I
would argue really
the benefits greatly
outweigh those challenges.
And I'm going to go through just
a couple of examples of things
I have found in my work as
kind of the sole arbiter
to have the highest leverage
in the work that I do.
And that's mostly
because that's mostly
leveraging the benefits
of our how easily it
can ease the burden
of repeated reporting.
Again, if that's a feature
of your job and again,
easily transfer and hold
institutional knowledge.
And so the first,
again, biggest leverage.
When that I have is
through the development
of internal packages.
If you don't as I didn't know
of started our packages do not
need to be public.
They do not need to live
on GitHub private packages
that only that are only for
you or only for your team.
And they can live
on a shared drive.
There's ways to export your
package to a shared drive,
and packages are incredibly
useful for having
easy access to common
data sets that you
use across multiple projects.
Also for documenting data,
definitions and calculations.
We can probably all agree
the documentation is a near
universal problem and I cannot
promise that this point.
And having data definitions
in your internal package
will solve that issue
or your organization.
But whether, your organization
uses a different enterprise
tool or internal wikis.
it is also really nice
to have those data, definitions
and calculations like right
at the fingertips of
people who are using them
when they're using them.
So again, the entire data
documentation problem,
but it can help solve it at the
very small micro level, even
if that's just and your
team and documenting
the data fields, functions,
et cetera that you use.
On a frequent basis.
And lastly, kind of
the most common thing
we think about what packages
are just packaging together
functions, right?
So very easy, of course,
an internal package
to track any common
analysis functions that you
use as well as plot themes.
And just as a specific
example, I obviously
do a lot of data analysis
and a small but frequent part
of my job is when people ask
me for to run an analysis
and create plots that other
people use to present.
Now I prefer to do my
presentations in Porto,
the province of my Porto, even
though how cool would that be?
And so they obviously use power.
I pretty frequently
again get asked to run,
rerun certain analyses to create
a plot that someone can drop
into a PowerPoint presentation.
And Thanks to my package,
I have several plot themes,
including one that is
specifically for plots created
for PowerPoint presentations.
I theme has my universities,
fonts and colors.
It has the font sizes that
I really well for PowerPoint
presentation, and I can again
very easily attach to plots
that I create and I can
really easily generate
all of those plots, save
them in a specific place
and even track and use
the specs that I know.
Again, work these specs work
perfectly for me with my theme
to create plots that look
cohesive and look appropriately
sized in the PowerPoint
templates that we use.
So again, just a very
small specific example
of how using the features
of internal packages
has really saved me a ton
of time over the years.
Likewise also being
able to leverage
parameterized reporting
with R Markdown and quota,
which I'm going to slightly
use interchangeably
in this example, but
whichever one you use or move
toward using.
As we all know so great,
because there are so many output
formats, including Microsoft
Office software formats,
if that's something
that you need or use.
And any kind of
parameterized reporting,
being able to leverage that
within R Markdown is so useful.
If you have, again, any
type of combinations
of code, text slots, data,
any invariant parameters.
Again, if repeated reporting
is any part of your job
guarantee that you'll be able
to find some efficiencies
through parameter reporting.
Again, just through
one example, let's say
you have an arm
Markdown file that
creates a PDF report that
has some text and some plots
and some tables.
And that you need to create
this report every year for,
let's say, each division
that you oversee
or that your group oversees.
We can use the render
function within R Markdown
to specify where
these files should
be saved, how they should
be titled, and then
use a little bit of functional
programming and render
that R Markdown file for a
given year for, let's say,
every unique value of
division within your data set.
And just that few lines of
code makes it extremely easy
to turn one R Markdown file
into a whole bunch of PDF files
again saving tremendous
amounts of time.
I have a few of these
similar projects
that I have to run
for reports that
get run a couple of times
a year for, in my case,
dozens of departments.
And having to do that
manually or quasi manually
through Tableau or word
or kind of other system
is just not nearly as efficient
as doing it in R Markdown.
So I would argue that we have
there are for sure struggles.
Again, to I'm not
going to pretend
that it's totally
smooth sailing if you
are the only person using
are at your workplace
and to kind of fit out
into an existing workflow.
But hopefully I
have demonstrated
that -- the benefits
of using are again
even if you only use specific
bits and pieces of R
to solve whatever specific
problems that you face you
can't use.
Again, an entire Ar
workflow is worth
overcoming whatever
specific struggles
you might face because it's true
that the less time you spend
reproducing your own analysis.
Again, I have been in that place
where you open an Excel file
from last year and you should
remember everything that you
did but don't.
And because it's excel,
it's not recorded very well,
it's not reproducible.
That is just wasted time.
Having to reproduce your own
analysis on any time interval
is really time wasted that could
more easily be made much more
efficient with R. And so the
last time you spend doing
that, the more time
you have for whatever
work it is, it's a line
of work that you find
important that you
are uniquely good at,
that you are able to put
your specific skills toward.
So hopefully this talk has
inspired you to again continue
to incorporate bits
and pieces of Ar
into your existing workflow,
even if you can't use
all of our other people use.
And I hope it has comforted
you that not everyone uses
the entire R ecosystem a to z.
That doesn't mean that you
aren't a real programmer,
you aren't a real coder.
As long as you're working
kind of within the constraints
of your job, you
can still find ways
to use R to help ease some
of your specific problems.
Thank you again.
Hopefully there are time
for questions, but if not,
I will be in the.
I will be in the Discord
server this afternoon.